folks here to present the Academy Award
for sound effects editing is an actress
so talented they've bestowed upon her
the heady honor of three names please
welcome the star of honeymoon in Vegas
and Miami Rhapsody Sarah Jessica Parker
for the past several years somebody has
explained what sound effects editing is
that's usually the high point of the
evening but this year I have some good
news and some better news the good news
is that the Academy's Board of Governors
all 36 of them are ready to come out
here and explain what sound effects
editing is the better news is that
instead we're going to show you who the
nominees are
Bruce Stambler and John Levesque for
clear and present danger gloria
exporters and randy tom for forrest gump
stephen hunter flick for speed
and the Oscar goes to Stephen hunter
flick for speed
I used to be a musician and one of the
ways we figured out how to make sound
effects were to take musical instruments
and break them anyway I'd like to thank
the Academy so very much for this award
I'd like to thank a terrific fabulous
crew that put together an extraordinary
soundtrack in no time at all I'd like to
thank John Wright for cutting the
picture and I'd like to thank my wife
Judy who was an editor on the project as
well I'd like to thank Ted Galliano and
Kim Cooper post-production at Fox and
I'd like to thank you on dibond
thank you thank you thank you